ok est-ce qu'on est là loïc là on est là
on est bien bien là ok aujourd'hui on se
fait mekhadma ça va pas nous prendre mon
temps parce qu'on l'a déjà fait
du coup c'est bon aujourd'hui on fait le
test your man benchmark pourquoi parce
que très récemment john cale l'a fait en
vidéo et dans cette vidéo il me mets au
défi me mets au challenge de réaliser un
score bien meilleur que lui il a dit
fabien olicard je te mets au défi de
faire une vidéo
il a mentionné quand il a dit fabien
olicard je te mets au défi de faire une
vidéo attend tourde je suis curieux
devant le score de fabien olicard je
pense que fabien olicard il fait une
suite infinie s'arrête pas alors pour
tracer une de ces vidéos on va dire
qu'il a dit ça comme ça ça me permet
aussi le mettre sur la vignette et ça
fait genre un petit peu un featuring tu
vois ouais ouais ouais
d'ailleurs j'avais une [ __ ] fait tester
ce truc en 2016 quand squeeze l'avais
fait je l'avais mis aussi sur la
vignette j'avais fait début aucune race
de ce côté là ne me citait pas en vidéo
sinon je fais la vidéo retour donc c'est
parti human benchmark l'avait fait en
deux pieds en 2016 parce que je faisais
une vidéo par jour donc là il faut voir
un peu ce que ça donne loïc explique nos
le concept de human benchmark plaisent
alors là tu fais tac tac tac qui fait
tous les trucs à prêter style est ok
alors oui bonjour c'est pour tout ce qui
est une lourd
ben on en manque la preuve je fais une
blague gauche par là une souris alors ré
a ction times ouais mais alors là déjà
ça commence par là parce que je suis sur
mac avec une souris comme ça mais loïc
[Musique]
162 2 131 des 134 pas la bonne son rival
de centre en 247 écoute mon score moyen
c'était 254 mon écoutera la souris sans
fil
c'est comme c'est comme ça que tu parles
de m'assurer
je suis un peu moins bon quand même
visuel memory mémoriser les quarts
je veux savoir puisque où l agent auquel
est l'organisme ne peut pas être en
dessous même score que jake ok c'est
parti le début c'est simple on est
clairement sur le même état d'esprit que
qui veut gagner des millions c'est tout
rôti
[Musique]
ok le level les huit premiers level ça
va après ça déconne dur
what the fuck il est beaucoup trop de
choses sur ça allait trop vite pompe à
merde [ __ ] le lot oui
level 13
[Musique]
là
ah [ __ ] quel dommage nouvelle 13 quand
même nouvelle 13 nouvelles 13
c'est pas mal 81% de quoi 80% de quoi
pourcentage calculé comprends pas je
suis supérieur à la moyenne le prochain
test et un deux trois points
d'interrogation c'est vrai que ce serait
cool ça va faire surtout si vous ne
suivez pas ma chaîne twitch elle est
dans la description
ok no man's land gettin' over you came
combien a fait joy cas à ce jeu à
l'époque 11 janka est arrivé à 11 je
n'ai pas le droit loïc d'être en dessous
11 hockey sarthe c'est parti là c'était
trois nouvelles 1 on était bon level 2
où on était bon allez y dépêche toi là
je fais trop chaud et puis quand je me
trompe et je vais avoir bien sommes
aussi 80,1 soixante dix on est bon pour
le v8 maintenant ce que je peux pas
utiliser mes méthodes de mémorisation et
me demande plus de temps que ça en fait
je suis obligé de dans le visuel c'est
ok pour le nouvel là on arrivait au
lever le neuf un peu les doigts de pied
en éventail
le v9 ces genres le pic statistiques là
où tout le monde arrive en fait et après
là c'est la chute
il faudrait que j'aille au level 11-12
quoi tu à 11 c comme jack à [ __ ] il a
fait un bon score en vrai un deuil car
un vraiment jordan il est choquant même
et si c level 12 ça fait plaise quoi
mais il faut déjà attendre le 11 hockey
658 680 décembre de l'année 85
ok pour le lever leviers sont les bons
le lot on est passé dans une tranche
agréable continuant 7 5 2 ou 5 7 2 7 5 2
je me sur 7 5 2 on est bon pour le level
donc là j'ai validé le level 11 là ça
passe vite ya plus il n'y a pas de
technique de mémoire possible là parce
que le temps d'apprentissage est
beaucoup trop court donc il faut être un
peu instante en fait dans le mémo
technique 591 86 700 euros 591 86 711
est entre les deux j'avais mémoriser
visuellement une jolie figure d 0880
level 12 validé en fait il me faut comme
ça une fois un truc visuel que je puisse
oublier et me dire ça je le mettrais et
retenir ce qu'il ya autour
allez c'est chaud là c'est cool 96 104
1000 29 96 104 1000 29 96 104 1029 assez
facile ça commençait par 1968 l'année de
mai 68 96 c'est l'année de naissance de
fanni qui travaillent ici donc en vrai
j'ai retenu sans 4029 sachant que 1029
ça me rappelle un petit peu aussi
tu sais les cartes mémoire les disques
durs et tout ça tu vois donc je suis sûr
de l'avoir levé le 13 est validée par
n'ai pas beaucoup sur le level 13 je
crois ah ouais là on est bien là j'me
fais un score l'a480 1,60 2206 81,62
1206 hockey 71 gelé retenu je sais pas
pourquoi 665 c'est le diable - 1 666 et
81 62 1260 2206 le revenu à la
répétition est ce que j'ai bon tuto
j'ai attaqué ce que j'ai pas fait de
bons à putte un j'oubliais 1,4 j'ai
oublié un chiffre j'ai juste oublié un
chiffre la moyenne des gens et ça c'est
nous allons n'est pas malin jojoy il
était là john thain a aucun risque
plaisir jojoy peut-être ça va rattraper
un peu le réaction times qui est
vraiment très mauvais l'appartement
verbal memory verbal memory il est là
qui permet ni world in charter memory as
possible
en fait tu cliques si c'est un mot que
tu as déjà vu tu cliques sur sin si
c'est un nouveau mot tu cliques sur mu
hockey quel était le score de ce char
joy suis trop con non 59e' hôpitaux ou
pourquoi j'ai relevé le défi
alors qu'ils n'avaient pas c'est ce que
j'ai
[Musique]
ça s'est déjà vu ah [ __ ] j'ai perdu un
point pour expliquer une vie j'ai déjà
passé les 100 points quand même un jeu à
102 points et joe licka qui était déjà
très chaud étaient à 59
je suis déconcentré besoin mais j'ai
trop fait le chou j'ai trop fait le show
et bien voir quand même on n'était pas
mauvais on est là là on va essayer le
truc du son truc du son je mette mes
écouteurs il a fait combien aux songes
eyeka [ __ ] c'est vraiment je joue ma
vie contre jordan
allez je crois qu'il est allé à 19
heures lille
hertz mais là on est vraiment juste sur
qu'est ce que ça donne quoi 18 1804
bourbon en gros je suis dans la moyenne
de jean canton de son très intéressant
ce test là pas du tout c'est la vitesse
à laquelle on tape
ok il faut que j'ai écrit le texte qui a
là c'est dommage parce que du coup c'est
en anglais ce qu'on peut pas anticiper
avec les reflex comme il l a fait ce
jojoy
allez c'est parti
mais c'est chaud parce que c'est en
anglais on ne peut pas anticiper mais il
faut faire les majuscules ou pas à temps
je fais un test un [ __ ] faut faire les
majuscules c'est vraiment ça compte pas
c'est un test pour voir mais il faut
tout respecté d'accord s'il en a
[ __ ] je suis revenu en arrière mais je
ne sais pas ce que ça va du versement
j'ai l'impression d'être ceux qui
traduisent les histoires de macron là je
te jure
[ __ ] little point virgule non mais
[ __ ] fait trop de fautes insight
fabien pas de fautes on a dit pas de
faute
pig arrête de faire des photos d'un
[ __ ] t'es y/y guen
tout auteur points 43 mots par minute
abel je suis pile poil un poil dans la
moyenne
un peu autant à dire vrai ce beauf 1ere
squat de test je suis moins bon que lui
quarante trois mots par minute c'est
moins bon que 47 permis je sauvegarde
j'ai un peu le seul musée vous allez
c'est parti
une fois de la place bon j'ai mis
difficultés je suis pas un gamer
donc je sais pas si je fais ça quel est
le trajet ne m'a souri à la rance et en
plus soit puis comme un porc pour
qu'elle réagisse
je dis pas ça parce que je vais être
nulle mais je vais tenu bon et score ils
sont pas bons clous bien des conti sont
pas bons à kevin la question elle est
mal répondu l'avait pas vite répondu
allez mal 548 c'est nul c'est le score
c'est très nul
regardons un peu les statistiques je
suis à moyenne plus haute que la moyenne
mais pas ouf quand même ok le dernier le
team tech est-ce que je suis plus
intelligent qu'un chimpanzé quel est le
score de nom de mon featuring du jour
vas-y je vais relativiser tout de suite
en disant que 12
jordan il a fait 12 ce qui est plutôt un
très bon score au test des chimpanzés en
gros il ya des cases qui vont apparaître
avec des chiffres derrière
après ça se cache il faut impliquer dans
l'ordre des numéros qui avait au départ
mais pas de temps bassil a forcément un
temps ananda corps pour l'instant c'est
ok d'accord c'est quand je commence à
cliquer que ça
[Musique]
ok bon comme d'hab j'aime me faire les
huit premiers niveaux
c'est facile c'est normal là après ça
commence à être bien plus comme c'est le
dernier test ça commençait à fatiguer un
mais c'est très cool comme c'est fou
comme un site aussi simple peut être si
passionnant
[Musique]
ok level 10 on est bon un deux trois
caps 4 5 7 9 10 ok pour 11
là ça commence vraiment être chaude
parce qu'il a plus de logique
1 2 3 ok
[Musique]
2 6 7 8 9 10 11
ok pour le level 11 passes le bel 12,7
en haut on revient 9
reut en eau 11 tous 13
ok allez vas-y pour le temps 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 et ça passe 14 1 2 3 4
on leur à ça c'est sur un coup franc 1 2
3 4
on sera 10 12 13 14 joueurs vas-y je
tente ou quoi aller 1 2 et 3a [ __ ] à
j'ai fait une faute et ça m'en remets à
nouveau quoi il ne me reste plus qu'un
seul essai pour ce dernier test
là je commence à voir ses oeuvres en
compote cécile fait la moindre erreur là
c'est terminé
1 2 3 4 5 6 gdi promis s'il séquence les
10 premiers dans ma tête et après les
quatre derniers jeux peut la voir
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ouais 11 12 13 14
ou à les entendre
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 13 14
on passe on passe aux 15 1 2 3 4 5
non j'ai pas le 3 là ok 1 2 3 et après 7
4 6
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
on passe mais qui est chaud ipass grave
on continue avec le 16 mai mais moi j'en
ai marre des [ __ ] j'ai envie de le
faire à l'arraché en même temps j'ai
envie de réussir
si je les jeunes les coins 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 je dis quoi
11 12 13 14 15 16 [ __ ] juillet il y en
a que 18 en parle 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 j'ai
plus envie de réfléchir louis blasi je
le fais lâche je le plante je n'aurai
pas de 3 4 5 6 7 6 collard ça m'a saoulé
mais franchement c'est pas mal je 99% et
est-ce qu'on a atteint un score final un
truc ou quoi quand comment ça se passe
là maintenant ainsi s'achève cette vidéo
là on a on a du pourcentage on sait à
peu près ce que ça de j'ai pas de
commentaire à faire
des fois c'était bon des fois c'était
moins bon en tout cas j'espère que ça
vous a plu je vous invite à regarder la
vidéo de jack à moi j'avais sorti une
vidéo vraiment en 2007 j'avais testé
j'ai pas pris le temps de regarder pour
comparer les scores mais vous pouvez
faire et me dire en commentaire aussi un
peu vos scores vous mais le jeu
également en description si vous voulez
le test merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
n'oubliez pas de la like et c'est
important et que vous abonner c'est
gratuit je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard ça ne change pas activer la
cloche pour voir les prochaines vidéos
ici je vous en mets deux ça attend ça
c'est mon compte instagram ça c'est bien
parce que c'est complémentaire de mes
vidéos mais voilà on va l'enlever
là je vous mets deux vidéos celle ci
c'est la vidéo quand j'avais fait ça en
2016 et ça c'est une vidéo sur comment
débloquer une compétence de son cerveau
qui est tout à fait en lien avec son
vainqueur aujourd'hui alors à très
bientôt chat